one leaders have gathered on the
southern coast of England to mark the
75th anniversary of d-day the day in
1944 when Allied forces landed in
Normandy and began to retake Europe from
Nazi Germany representatives of 16
nations joined Britain's Queen Elizabeth
at the ceremony in Portsmouth where many
of the troops embarked for Normandy on
June 5th 1944 among them among the
leaders are French president Emmanuel
macron in German Chancellor Angela
Merkel u.s. President Donald Trump
tribute the Allied soldiers sailors and
airmen who gave their lives in the
invasion the stars of the day are the
veterans of that campaign some 300 are
taking part in the commemorations Nadira
began with Operation Overlord a massive
naval operation to ferry American
British Canadian and other Allied forces
across the English Channel to the French
coast now it remains the largest assault
of its kind in the history of modern
warfare some 7,000 ships and landing
craft headed for a 50-mile stretch of
the French coast and the code names of
those landing beaches are etched in
history Utah Omaha gold Juno and sword
today's commemorations didn't begin in
France though but at the English naval
base of Portsmouth from where d-day
veterans are to depart on a ship for
France also in Portsmouth is our
correspondent Charlotte Potts who is
covering those commemoration ceremonies
for us shall I tell us what's been
happening there so far to mark d-day
yes it was here in Portsmouth where the
Allied forces thousands of soldiers were
leaving in 44 you can see the harbor
behind me and this is where the ships
were departing for Normandy this is also
where this commemoration ceremony just
took place with sixteen world leaders
there on stage reliving and reenacting
that memory of the day and in keeping
that memory alive with musical
performances the world leaders read
poems or diary entries from soldiers in
parts a very emotional event and there's
also something that concrete that came
out of this event a d-day Proclamation a
pledge from those world leaders that to
ensure that those horrific events of
World War two will never be repeated
again and that conflict should be
resolved peacefully and there are lots
of guests who are attending the
ceremonies the Queen is there 16 world
leaders up there but the main heroes of
the event really are the veterans some
of them are also attending the
commemorations aren't they absolutely
Amrita there's 300 veterans that
attended the ceremony here they are all
over 90 years old of course now and they
were really at the center stage of the
ceremony it was all surrounding them
honoring them the Queen the Queen
addressed them in her speech she said I
am part of that war generation and I
know the sacrifices you have made for us
to live in freedom so very emotional
there and now those veterans are meeting
with world leaders with the Queen must
be a very interesting experience for
them at that age and those veterans will
be departing on a ship tonight from this
harbor to Normandy where those events
will continue to take place those
commemoration events will continue
tomorrow so much of symbolism and so
much of history Charlotte before we
continue our conversation let's take a
look at the events of 75 years ago and
at some of d-days legacy
at first glance it's hard to see any
sign of the horrors that this stretch of
sand played host to but 75 years ago on
June 6th the fate of an entire continent
rested on the soldiers who came ashore
here on Omaha Beach Operation Overlord
saw a combined force of nearly 160,000
American British and Canadian troops
land on the beaches of Normandy gaining
a foothold in nazi-occupied France came
at a heavy price the fighting on d-day
and the weeks afterwards claimed the
lives of tens of thousands of Allied
soldiers but their sacrifice hastened
the defeat of Hitler's Third Reich
commemorating the Fallen became an
important ritual for the victorious
Allied powers a reminder that they
fought on the side of right in a just
war the Germans also suffered heavy
casualties but it wasn't until 2004 that
France invited a German Chancellor to
take part in the annual commemorations
what was once viewed in Germany as a
calamitous defeat is now seen as marking
the start of the long road to peace and
liberation the successful invasion
completely changed Europe for the best
they brought us democracy we lost the
war we've had 70 years of peace here all
the people lying in the cemeteries there
this is what goes through my head when I
visit them on d-day all those people
died for us so that we could live in
peace Gustav demetria Lucan when France
and Germany first commemorated the
invasion of Normandy together it was
seen by observers as a sign of deepening
European unity in the face of straining
transatlantic ties and faced with
threats both foreign and domestic the
bond of European unity continues to be
put to the test seventy-five years after
the events of d-day
we're telling nourish Charlotte bottles
in Portsmouth Charlotte German
Chancellor Angela Merkel is also
attending the ceremonies explained to us
the significance and the symbolism of
having a German Chancellor at these
commemorations yeah of course amorita
there's a huge significance behind that
it wasn't until 2004 we just heard that
a German Chancellor participated in
these events of course huge significance
there and also this day is just it was a
key event in world war ii that really
changed the course of history and
created a new world order a new world
order established on democracy and peace
it created after that the United Nations
and the European Union and these
institutions and values have now come
under pressure by u.s. President Donald
Trump but also for example by the
British decision to leave the European
Union so it's interesting to see these
world leaders uniting today and coming
together in a peaceful way 75 years
after those nations really fought each
other to the death right Charlotte parts
are covering the commemoration
ceremonies in Portsmouth in southern
England thank you very much